pour la première fois de l'histoire de
la vème république une peine de prison
est requise contre un ancien président
mardi à l'issue de cinq heures de
réquisitoire les procureurs du parquet
national financiers ont requis quatre
ans de prison dont deux ferme à
l'encontre de nicolas sarkozy de l'ex
haut magistrat gilbert azibert et de
l'avocat thierry herzog pour corruption
et trafic d'influencé
une peine assortie de cinq ans
d'interdiction professionnelle pour ce
dernier qui est aussi l'avocat
historique de l'ex maire de neuilly sur
seine
lors de son réquisitoire le procureur
adjoint jean luc blachon n'a pas épargné
nicolas sarkozy l'effet ne se serait pas
produit si un ancien président avocat
par ailleurs avait gardé à l'esprit la
grandeur la responsabilité et les
devoirs de la charge qui fut la sienne
la république n'oublie pas assez
président ne serait ce que parce qu'ils
font l'histoire
al'inverse on ne peut pas admettre d'un
ancien président qu'il oublie la
république et ce qu'elle porte depuis
plusieurs décennies un état de droit
très critiqué ces derniers mois par une
partie de la classe politique notamment
à droite est visé par le pilonnage
intensif de la défense le parquet
national financier est sous pression
une situation qui a contraint le patron
de l'institution
jean-françois monnaire à descendre dans
l'arène pour défendre ses collègues la
lourde charge du parquet est d'appliquer
le droit et de faire respecter la loi
ce procès n'est pas une vengeance
institutionnels ni celle de la
magistrature et encore moins celle du
parquet national financiers personne ici
ne cherchent à se venger d'un ancien
président de la république comme toute
personne un ancien chef de l'état des
droits mais il a aussi d'impérieux
devoir de respecter lui-même le droit
les peines encourues par les prévenus
pouvaient aller jusqu'à dix ans de
prison et un million d'euros d'amendé
un réquisitoire moins sévère donc et qui
impressionne peu l'avocate de nicolas
sarkozy
jacqueline laffont je dirais que le
parti a déserté l'accusation et
qu'aujourd'hui il a parlé très fort il a
proposé des peines qui ne sont que des
pannes proposé l'a d'ailleurs rappelé du
même ce ne sont que des réquisitions et
encore une fois je n'ai aucun doute nous
démontrons ses réquisitions parce que
encore une fois elles ont été démontées
des chats au cours de l'audience et que
ce sera très facile pour nous de faire
après les réquisitions la parole est à
la défense
les plaidoiries auront lieu aujourd'hui
et demain le jugement sera ensuite mis
en délibéré